PRESIDENT TRUMP.
IMPEACHMENT.
HOW THEY MIGHT TURN THEIR BLUE
WAVE INTO A BLUE RIPPLE.
I WILL EXPLAIN.
WE BEGIN WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP ON
WE BEGIN WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP O
THE VERGE OF A TRULY HISTORIC
DIPLOMATIC TRIUMPH IS HIS TOUGH
TALK APPEARS TO BE PAYING OFF.
THE LEADERS OF NORTH AND SOUTH
KOREA, THIS WAS WILD, AGREED IN
PRINCIPLE TODAY TO REMOVE ALL
NUCLEAR WEAPONS FROM THEIR
COUNTRY.
AND TO WORK TOWARD FORMALLY
ENDING THE STATE OF WAR THAT HAS
ENDING THE STATE OF WAR THAT HA
EXISTED SINCE THE 1953 TRUCE.
TRUMP WAS ECSTATIC OVER THE NEW
TWEETING EARLY IN THE DAY KOREAN
TWEETING EARLY IN THE DAY KOREA
WAR TO END.
THEY THE PRESIDENT LATER
ACKNOWLEDGED THERE WAS MUCH WORK
ACKNOWLEDGED THERE WAS MUCH WOR
TO BE DONE,  BUT HE SURE SOUNDE
OPTIMISTIC.
>> A LOT OF GOOD THINGS ARE
HAPPENING WITH RESPECT TO NORTH
KOREA, PRESIDENT OBAMA TOLD ME
WHEN I HAD THE ONE MEETING WITH
HIM HE SAID THAT YOUR BIGGEST
PROBLEM.
THAT'S THE MOST DIFFICULT THING
YOU HAVE.
HONESTLY, I WISH IT WAS HANDLED
EARLIER AND I WISH IT WAS
HANDLED BY ANOTHER
ADMINISTRATION YEARS AGO.
I'M NOT JUST TALKING ABOUT
PRESIDENT OBAMA.
I GO BACK TO ANY ADMINISTRATION
YOU WANT.
OVER THE LAST 25 YEARS, THIS
SHOULD'VE BEEN HANDLED A LONG
TIME AGO.
THEY SHOULD NOT HAVE, FOR ME TO
HANDLE.
WE WILL HANDLE IT.
WE ARE HANDLING IT WELL.
>> LAURA: IS IT TIME FOR TRIMS
CRITICS TO SUCCEED THAT HIS
TOUGH ROCKET MAN TALK ON THE
SANCTIONS WITH NORTH KOREA MADE
A DIFFERENCE HERE?
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN Mc
MASTER HAS BEEN URGING
COLLEAGUES TO SUPPORT A NOBEL
PEACE PRIZE FOR THE PRESIDENT.
HE JOINS US NOW FROM FORT WAYNE,
HE JOINS US NOW FROM FORT WAYNE
INDIANA AND FORMER TRUMP
CAMPAIGN ADVISER IN ADVISOR IN
CHINA POLICY EXPERT MIKE
PILLSBURY IS GOING TO BE WITH US
PILLSBURY IS GOING TO BE WITH U
IS IS ASIA POLICY EXPERT RILEY
WALTERS OF THE HERITAGE
FOUNDATION.
THIS IS I NEVER THOUGHT I WOULD
SEE THIS IN MY LIFETIME.
I HAVE TO SAY.
THE IDEA OF THE NORTH KOREAN
DICTATOR CROSSING TO MEET THE
SOUTH KOREAN LEADER, OBVIOUSLY
SPEAKING THE SAME LANGUAGE.
MEETING TOGETHER, EMBRACING AT
ONE POINT AFTER THE HANDSHAKE,
AFTER THEY HAD THEIR MEETING.
THIS IS INITIAL STILL IN ITS
INITIAL PHASES, BUT CONGRESSMAN,
INITIAL PHASES, BUT CONGRESSMAN
I HAVE TO SAY I THINK THE ONLY
PERSON WHO COULD HAVE GOTTEN AS
TO THIS PLACE, AGAIN, WE WILL
SEE WHERE IT GOES, BUT DONALD
TRUMP BECAUSE OF HIS
UNCONVENTIONAL APPROACH TO
NEGOTIATIONS AND FRANKLY HIS
TOUGH TALK.
PEOPLE SAY YOU'RE GOING TO
LAUNCH A NUCLEAR WAR, HE SAID NO
LAUNCH A NUCLEAR WAR, HE SAID N
BUT WE'RE GOING TO SOLVE THIS.
CONGRESSMAN, HOW DO DONALD TRUMP
CONGRESSMAN, HOW DO DONALD TRUM
GET US THIS FAR?
>> WHAT IS EXTRAORDINARY, AND
YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN SAYING FOR A
COUPLE OF MONTHS NOW IT'S NORTH
KOREA ACTUALLY IS ITS NUCLEAR
PROGRAM AND YOU BRING PEACE TO
THE STINN PENINSULA AFTER 70
YEARS, DONALD TRUMP DESERVES A
NOBEL PEACE PRIZE.
THE ONLY REASON THAT THE EVIL
NORTH KOREAN DICTATOR IS COMING
TO THE TABLE IS BECAUSE THERE IS
TO THE TABLE IS BECAUSE THERE I
A NEW SHERIFF IN TOWN AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP TWITTER
DIPLOMACY IS WORKING.
HIS TOUGH TALK IS MAKING A
DIFFERENCE.
IT'S BRINGING NORTH AND SOUTH
KOREA TO THE TABLE IN CHINA TOO.
OF COURSE, WE HAVE A LONG WAY T
GO, BUT THE EVENTS OF THE LAST
24 HOURS ARE EXTRAORDINARY AND
ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE TO OVERSTATE.
IT'S A VERY BIG DEAL AND IT IS
HAPPENING BECAUSE OF PRESIDENT
TRUMPS LEADERSHIP.
>> LAURA: WE WILL TALK ABOUT
THE CHINESE INVOLVEMENT IN ALL
OF THIS BREAD WE CAN'T OVERLOOK
THE FACT THAT WE HAVE MAJOR
ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS GOING
TO CHINA ON TUESDAY.
SENIOR-LEVEL OF THE MINISTRATION
SENIOR-LEVEL OF THE MINISTRATIO
DEMONSTRATION GOING TO TALK
TRADE.
MIKE, I WANT TO TALK TO YOU.
I WANT TO DO FLASHBACK IT IS A
BIT OF A FLASHBACK FRIDAY HIM
PLAY FOR OUR INTERNAL BEST SEEN
FROM THE NOBEL PRIZE CEREMONY
INVOLVING BARACK OBAMA.
LET'S WATCH.
TAKE TO KEEP THE TENACITY TO HOP
TAKE TO KEEP THE TENACITY TO HOE
TAKE TO KEEP THE TENACITY TO HO
AND MAKE THESE HOPES COME TRUE.
THAT IS WHAT MAKES HIM SO
IMPORTANT BY HIS OWN BEHAVIOR
AND LEADERSHIP, HE IS DEMANDING
THAT WE ALL TAKE A SHARE OF
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE RESPONSE
TO GLOBAL CHALLENGES.
WE CONGRATULATE THIS YEARS
WINNER, PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA
ON WHAT HE HAS ALREADY ACHIEVED.
HALF MONTH, HE WAS GETTING
PEOPLE TO ACCEPT RESPONSIBILITY
FOR FACING GLOBAL CHANGES.
IF THAT IS THE BENCHMARK, THEN
DONALD TRUMP REGARDLESS OF WHAT
HAPPENED, HAS TO BE ALMOST A
SHOO-IN FOR THE NOBEL.
I THINK THE TIMING IS RIGHT HERE
.
>> I AGREE.
PERHAPS PRESIDENT TRUMP DESERVED
PERHAPS PRESIDENT TRUMP DESERVE
TO NOBEL PEACE PRIZES.
AS YOU KNOW THE AUTHORITY OF THE
AS YOU KNOW THE AUTHORITY OF TH
PEACE PRIZES IS SOMEWHAT IN
DOUBT.
IT'S A COMMITTEE OF FIVE WHO AR
CHOSEN BY THE NORWEGIAN
PARLIAMENT AND THEY TEND TO BE
RETIRED MEMBERS OF THE NORWEGIAN
RETIRED MEMBERS OF THE NORWEGIA
PARLIAMENT SO THAT MADE THE
MISTAKES OVER THE YEARS, PEOPLE
WHO NOBEL PEACE PRIZE WAS NOT
EARNED.
IN THE CASE OF PRESIDENT TRUMP,
THIS IS A TREMENDOUS SUCCESS.
THE ONLY PROBLEM IS THE DEGREE
OF PRESSURE USED HE USED TO GET
IT MADE TURNED THE STOMACHS OF
SOME OF THE NORWEGIAN MEMBERS OF
SOME OF THE NORWEGIAN MEMBERS O
PARLIAMENT.
HE HAD NUCLEAR AIRCRAFT WING
TOWARD NORTH KOREA HE HAD AT
DISCUSSION WITH THE SOUTH KOREA
DEFENSE MINISTER THAT WE MIGHT
RETURN OUR NUCLEAR WEAPONS TO BE
RETURN OUR NUCLEAR WEAPONS TO B
DEPLOYED AGAIN IN SOUTH KOREA AS
DEPLOYED AGAIN IN SOUTH KOREA A
AS MANY AS 800 OR MORE.
OTHER KIND OF PRESSURE WAS
MASSIVE IN VERY FOCUSED
SANCTIONS EVEN ON THE ROYAL
FAMILY IN THE NORTH.
THIS IS NOT YOU'RE NORMAL
IDEALISTIC MAKE A SPEECH KIND O
NOBEL PEACE PRIZE CANDIDACY.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT GOT
RESULTS.
THE RESULT CAME ONLY THROUGH
PRESSURE.
I THINK THE CHINESE ALSO HELPED.
FRANKLY, PRESIDENT TRUMP LINKING
FRANKLY, PRESIDENT TRUMP LINKIN
TRADE AND THE DELEGATION GOING
NEXT WEEK TO HELPING WITH NORTH
KOREA WAS A VERY BOLD GESTURE
HEAVILY CRITICIZED BY THE
LEFT-WING MEDIA.
IT LOOKS LIKE IT WAS A STROKE OF
IT LOOKS LIKE IT WAS A STROKE O
GENIUS.
THE CHINESE HELPED US ON NORTH
KOREA.
>> LAURA: I THINK THAT'S A
GREAT POINT.
RILEY, I WANT TO GET YOU ON THIS
.
FRANKLY, I'M A LITTLE WORRIED
WITH THE LINKING OF CHINA TRADE
TO NORTH KOREA.
OBVIOUSLY THE CHOICE BETWEEN
NUCLEAR WAR OR THE CHINA 2025
PROGRAM WHERE THEY DOMINATE
EVERY MAJOR INDUSTRY, IT IS NOT
THE EASIEST OF CONCERNS TO LOOK
AT WHEN YOU LOOK AT THEM BOTH.
WE CAN'T ALLOW CHINA TO DOMINATE
WE CAN'T ALLOW CHINA TO DOMINAT
HIGH-TECH.
WE CAN'T ALLOW CHINA TO DOMINATE
WE CAN'T ALLOW CHINA TO DOMINAT
3D PRINTING, COMMERCIAL AVIATION
, BUT THAT IS THEIR
SUBSIDIZING GOLD.
THEY ARE DOING THAT ACROSS EVER
INDUSTRY, AND I'M WORRIED THAT
DONALD TRUMP IS SO FOCUSED ON
THE NORTH KOREA DEAL, THAT WILL
LET UP THE PRESSURE ON CHINA
THAT ALSO IS NECESSARY.
SO FAR HE'S DONE A GREAT JOB.
TO GET THERE IS DEFINITELY A
DIFFERENCE IN OPINION OF WHAT IS
DIFFERENCE IN OPINION OF WHAT I
THE IMMEDIATE THREAT FROM NORTH
KOREA AND THE FUTURE THREAT FROM
KOREA AND THE FUTURE THREAT FRO
CHINA REPRESENT.
OBVIOUSLY LAST NIGHT WAS
HISTORIC IT WAS SETTING UP
TOWARD THE UPCOMING MEETINGS
BETWEEN THE LEADER OF NORTH
KOREA AND DONALD TRUMP.
CHINA'S ROLE IN THIS GOING
FORWARD IS SKEPTICAL I THINK.
THE PRESIDENT OF CHINA HAS THE
NORTH KOREAN LEADER COME VISIT
HIM ALMOST OUT OF THE BLUE IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT A COUPL
OF MONTHS AGO TO PREEMPT HIS
VISIT OR THE NORTH KOREA'S
LEADERS VISIT WITH SOUTH KOREA
IN THE UNITED STATES.
I THINK THE MAXIMUM PRESSURE OF
THE UNITED STATES HAVE BEEN
APPLYING HAS BEEN INFLUENCING
AND INCENTIVIZING NORTH KOREAN
SUCCUMB TO THE TABLE AND THAT
CHINESE TO RECIPROCATE.
TAKE CONGRESSMAN, I WANT TO PLA
FOR YOU IN A PANEL A FEW OF OUR
FAVORITE FRIENDS ON THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE AISLE WHO REFUSED TO
SIDE OF THE AISLE WHO REFUSED T
GIVE PRESIDENT TRUMP EVEN A
MODICUM OF CREDIT HERE.
LET'S WATCH.
>> PEOPLE SIT AND TALK ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP OR ANYBODY IN NORT
OR SOUTH KOREA WINNING THE NOBE
PEACE PRIZE.
KEEP MY MESSAGE FOR PRESIDENT
TRUMP TONIGHT IS CURB YOUR
ENTHUSIASM.
DON'T SET UP UNREALISTIC
EXPECTATIONS FOR THE SUMMIT THEY
EXPECTATIONS FOR THE SUMMIT THE
THAT KEMPE PROPOSAL BECAUSE IF
YOU DO HAVE THESE EXPECTATIONS
AND APPEALS, THAT MAY DRAW US
CLOSER TO WAR.
>> THIS WAS THE SHOW THAT NO ON
ELSE IS IN CONTROL AND CHINA AND
ELSE IS IN CONTROL AND CHINA AN
THE UNITED STATES IS NOT IN
CONTROL.
THE TWO KOREAS ARE SEIZING THE
PROCESS.
>> LAURA: OKAY.
THEY JUST CAME TOGETHER.
IT WAS LIKE PIXIE DUST AND THEY
CAME TOGETHER.
THAT LAST COMMENT OF ALL THE TOM
THAT LAST COMMENT OF ALL THE TO
COMMENT I'VE HEARD, THAT LAST
COMMENT WAS AMONG THE MOST
MORONIC.
TAKE ONE, THE PRESIDENT FOR
STRING OF THAT'S PART OF OUR IN
THIS POSITION IN THE FIRST PLACE
.
>> LAURA: HE CANNOT LET UP ON
CHINA.
THEY ARE RIPPING APART AT EVERY
TURN.
JUST BECAUSE IT HELPED ON NORTH
KOREA DOESN'T MEAN WE CAN LET
THEM UP BECAUSE THEY ARE POISED
TO DOMINATE ALL THESE INDUSTRIES
.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
WE ARE WHERE WE ARE BECAUSE THE
PRESIDENT HAS SHOWN STRENGTH.
HE WILL SHOW STRING FOR CHINA.
YOU'RE YOU SEE THEM CAVING IN.
HERE IS THE DEAL, THE WITHERING
CRITICISM OF FOLKS ON THE LEFT,
CAN YOU IMAGINE HOW THEY WOULD
BE BEHAVING IF BARACK OBAMA WAS
PRESIDENT AND YOU HAD EVENTS
LIKE LAST NIGHT.
I AM RUNNING FOR THE UNITED
STATES AND AGAINST THE
DEMOCRATIC SENATOR WHO LIKE ALL
THOSE OTHERS ON THE LEFT HAVE
CRITICIZED THIS PRESIDENTS
DIPLOMACY.
TWITTER DIPLOMACY IS WORKING.
NORTH KOREA HAS COME TO THE
TABLE IN A WAY THAT MOST OF US
WOULD'VE NEVER IMAGINED JUST A
FEW MONTHS AGO.
YOU CANNOT OVERSTATE HOW BIG OF
A DEAL MUST NIGHT WAS.
OF COURSE, THERE'S A LONG WAY TO
OF COURSE, THERE'S A LONG WAY T
GO, BUT WE ARE HERE BECAUSE
AMERICA IS SAFEST WHEN AMERICA
IS STRONG.
WITH THIS PRESIDENT, PRESIDENT
TRUMP, WE ARE STRONG AGAIN ON
THE WORLD STAGE.
TO HAVE A FENCE LIKE WHAT IT
HAPPENED IN THE LAST 24 HOURS IS
HAPPENED IN THE LAST 24 HOURS I
JUST ANOTHER BIG STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION.
I AGREE WITH YOU.
WE'VE GOT TO BE STRONG TOWARD
CHINA.
THIS PRESIDENT IS STEPPING
FORWARD TO GETTING TOUGH ON
CHINA IN A WAY THAT HASN'T